bonjour alexis
jours elle a préalablement à l'examen de
ce projet de loi sur le pass vaccinale
le ministre de la santé est auditionné
par les députés pour quelles raisons
bien pour savoir ce qu'il en retourne
pourquoi impasse vaccinale après les
chèques du pass sanitaires olivier
ferrand ministre de la santé toujours
dans la capacité 1 de statuer sur le
nombre de doses qui seront nécessaires
si les parlementaires votent se passe
alors nous n'avons aucun moyen de
revenir en arrière ni aucune garantie
sur la durée réelle de ce pass combien
de doses si ces cinq doses par an ça
veut dire impasse vaccinale avis ça veut
dire une société fragmentée avis une
société de la stigmatisation et
finalement avec des résultats sanitaires
marginaux regardez le résultat du bac
simple du masque des mesures de
distanciation physique du pass
sanitaires on n'a jamais vu autant de
cas alors ça ne veut pas dire autant de
malades parce qu'on a été obligés de
tester avant les fêtes mais on marche
littéralement sur la tête ça ne peut pas
continuer ainsi il est temps que à la
fois les juges les responsables du droit
reprennent le pouvoir et la raison parce
que visiblement les contre-pouvoirs ont
démissionné dans ce pays en particulier
le conseil d'état qui valide une mesure
qui est contraire à la constitution et
contraire même à l'esprit de ce qui est
la nation française alors qu'attendre
selon vous de cette audition d'olivier
ferrand alexis
aurait un des circonvolutions comme à
l'habitude qu'à l'accoutumée olivier
ferrand va sans doute enchaîner des
contrevérités et d à peu près en disant
que potentiellement on imagine on espère
il est à espérer que etc vous le
connaissez maintenant ligue et veyran il
a dit tout et son contraire depuis des
mois rappelez vous il garantissait que
le pass sanitaire serait limitée dans le
temps il garantissait que le pass
sanitaire ne serait pas utilisé pour les
activités du quotidien qui peut encore
donner un quelconque crédit à la parole
de ce ministre de ce gouvernement c'est
la question que je me pose est que se
posent de nombreux français qui continue
d'obéir contraint forcé vu la somme des
amendes maintenant si jamais vous n'êtes
pas obligé de vous vacciner puisqu'il
s'agit d'une obligation vaccinale
déguisé c'est ça qui est proprement
scandaleux ça m'avait été dit pas gérant
lui-même alors qui d'autre doit être
auditionné par cette commission
il faudrait auditionné emmanuel macron
ce serait bien de l'avoir également le
premier ministre et puis les
responsables de la haute autorité de
santé ainsi que le conseil de défense
sanitaire ce conseil de défense
sanitaire doit être dissous on ne peut
pas continuer à mettre la démocratie
entre parenthèses à faire en sorte que
toutes les décisions soient pris sous le
sceau du secret défense les citoyens
méritent la transparence face à ces
décisions qui sont illisible
incompréhensible et dangereuse pour nos
libertés
merci beaucoup c'était l'édito politique
d'alexis poulain sur arte france